Ce qui est bien avec les commentaires sur Internet c'est que, au moins les gens ils disent pas tout et n'importe quoi :)
FAUX !!!!
Déjà ce qui est génial c'est les mec qui s'engueulent et qui se fightent par commentaire interposé
C 'est pas la façon la plus virile du monde de se battre quand même^^
Pffff (soupire) je me suis peffra avec un mec je l'ai démonté
Ah  tu t'es battu dans la rue ?
Non non sur YouTube !
Sur internet les gens ils pèsent pas leurs mot, donc c'est le seul endroit au monde ou tu pourras lire par exemple ça :
NUL !!
Tu peux pas dire ça dans la vrai vie
*I can believe in you*
NUL !!
Sur YouTube ils existe la team des pouces verts
La team des pouces verts, c'est les mecs qui s'en foutent du bac, des meufs...
Eux, ils ont un objectif dans la vie !
WAHOU, JE SUIS EN TOP COMMENTAIRE !!
Nicolas, je suis enceinte !
Je m'en bas les couilles je suis en top commentaires !
Le regards d'une femme
Le sourire de ton gamin
Etre en top commentaires ça vaut bien plus que tout ça
C'est vrai qu'il y'a pas beaucoup de gens qui mettent des pouces rouges...
Mettre un pouce rouge c'est quand même une action un peu... pleine de haine, un peu vénère !
Je me demande a quoi ils ressemblent les mecs qui mettent des pouces rouges
JE DETESTENT L'HUMOUR
JE VOUS HAIS TOUS
POUCE ROUGE ,AHHHH JE JOUIE !!!!
Après il y'a les snobes
Les snobes ils mettent un type de commentaire
C'est un mot, enfin plus une honomatopée...
Pfff... pfff...
Bon après il y'a les geeks, entre 8 et 10 ans
C'est les mecs qui mettent pleins de smileys comme si les gars avaient plein d'expressions de visage en même temps
Moi, je suis le smiley blazé...
Ou alors ils mettent plein de XD XD
Ça veut dire que peut être que le mec derrière son écran il est comme ça :
Après il y'a l'intello centriste :
Il est ni trop là --> ni trop là <--
C'est le mec qui veut calmer jeu, qui veut pas trop qu'on s'énerve sur YouTube
Amen
Après il y'a les vieux
Quand il y'a un vieux qui met un commentaire sur Internet, tu le grilles tout de suite
Irenne, c'est comme même chic Internet
Les Américains sur YouTube, quand ils tombent sur une vidéo française, ils font toujours le même commentaires
Y'a pas mal de mec aussi qui essayent de faire leurs pub par le biais de commentaires YouTube
EH MOI AUSSI, MOI AUSSI JE VAIS PAREIL
MOI AUSSI JE FAIS PAREIL !!
Y'a les Firsters, c'est les mec qui mettent des first
Allez sors une vidéo, sors une vidéo
FIRST, FIRST !!
AHHHH! Oh putain j'suis first!
Oh putain!
Bon évidement il y a les donneurs de leçon
Ce qui est marrant avec eux, c'est que ça perds toute crédibilité quand c'est bourré de fautes d'orthographe
Lui, au moins, il a compris
Après il y a les rageux, mais les rageux on ne peut rien y faire
Bon après, il y a le mec qui s'est trompé de site
Oh merde! Oh merde!
EFFACER! EFFACER!
Après il y a le commentaire WTF
Mais le meilleur commentaire Internet
C'est le tiens
Si tu veux tu peux t'abonner à ma chaîne YouTube en cliquant ici
Ou alors tu peux regarder mes autres vidéos en cliquant dessus avec ta souris
Mais surtout...
OUBLIE PAS DE LÂCHER UN COM!